ich habe vor ein paar tagen einen
facebook post gemacht indem ich euch
eben erklärt habe wie es momentan bei
mir im leben so aussieht ich stehe
nämlich kurz vor meinem prüfungen
vermeiden
absolut endlich schlussendlich letzten
prüfungen in meinem leben hoffentlich
steht kurz vorm zweiten staatsexamen und
habe noch drei prüfungen vor mir und
sind deswegen im moment zeitlich und
seelisch und mit den nerven etwas
angespannt was glaube ich ziemlich
nachvollziehbar ich und mein ehemann ist
es weiter alles ab aber ganz egal
auf jeden fall habe ich im moment
einfach etwas wenig zeit überhaupt für
die ganze youtube sache und für euch und
möchte mich deswegen entschuldigen oder
zu entschuldigen
ich möchte ich einfach sagen dass ich
kann nicht so viel zeit zum beantworten
eure fragen habt aber ich will mich
trotzdem darum jeden abend zum ersten
mal reinzuschauen und über befragen
zuschauen jedem zumindest mein kommentar
zu lassen und außerdem hat sich dank
unter der woche am dienstag im
fernsehteam angekündigt welches schon am
mittwoch da war das war ein leichter
organisatorischer stresst das alles dann
runter hut zu bekommen auf jeden fall
was sehr anstrengend aber auch sehr
schön eine ganz tolle erfahrung für mich
und ich darf mich eigentlich gar nicht
mehr verraten aber wenn man so ein es
ums ganze ausgestrahlt sage ich ich auf
jeden fall bescheid ich denke es wird
eine ganz gute und ganz große sache und
mehr dazu erfahren
derzeit ist ich habe mir die flecker
bakery gekauft weil mich dieses
titelbild total angemacht hat mit diesem
leckeren kuchen und diesen leckeren
kuchen den sie jetzt ihr möchte ich
jetzt natürlich nach machen werde ich
jetzt einfach mal zeigen was zum kuchen
ist und zwar wird der außen in brüssel
boden hergestellt also kekse und mutter
und dann kommt da so ein kleiner
frischkäse kuchen rein also käsekuchen
und den möchte ich jetzt auf jeden fall
ausprobieren und zeigt euch am besten
mal die zutaten die ich für die brösel
boden braucht das ganze backe ich in
einer 18 zentimeter springform und dann
müsst ihr auch wirklich springform
nehmen und keine back rahmen
wieso und weshalb das erfahrt ihr später
und zwar braucht er dafür nur zwei
zutaten einmal 50 gramm butter und
einmal 115 gramm kekse
wenn ihr zum beispiel - allergie habt
oder erdnüsse nicht mögt neben der
andere kekse eben - freier kekse wie
butterkekse ich hab jetzt die erdnuss
kekse von leibnitz arbeitet gibt es mit
sicherheit auch immer günstigeren
version in diesem neuen produkt habe ich
jetzt aber einfach nicht gefunden
die kekse müssen jetzt noch zerkleinert
werden und das mache ich einfach in so
einem kleinen mitra können natürlich
jeden anderen mixa nehmen
daher ist ziemlich klein deswegen in
zwei portionen fleisch richtung einfach
in eine kleine schüssel um die butter
gespalten werden
ich werde sind einfach ganz schön in der
mikrowelle mache natürlich keine
mikrowelle habt kann es auch in einem
kleinen topf machen und dann gehen uns
geld wieder die butter ist jetzt
geschmolzen
sieht so aus und dann gebe ich sie
einfach mit hier in die keksdose köln
und vermischt das ganze
also die masse sollte dann so sein dass
sie eben fest bleibt wenn ihr sie
zusammen geklebt und jetzt werde ich
noch meine springform frau behalten dazu
habe ich hier ein kleines stück
backpapier geben eine springform und
schneit außen um einfach den rand und es
hilft später einfach dass dieser brösel
boden später nicht an der ford lebt und
dass sich die torte später schön raus
bekommen
muss nicht ganz perfekt sein aber eben
schon gleichmäßig diesen keks brösel
boden gebe ich jetzt für etwa eine
viertelstunde in die gefriertruhe können
dann natürlich auch im kühlschrank leben
da würde ich selber etwas länger trennen
lassen und über den derzeit schon mal
die führung zu behalten und dafür zeige
ich mich jetzt einmal die zutaten für
die füllung braucht ihr 530 gramm
frischkäse an sich egal welche marke
benutzt dass ich jetzt die hier all die
marke ihr braucht zwei eier 130 gramm
zucker 25 gramm kakaopulver bangkok
einen kara und 130 gramm schlagsahne
diese zutaten stelle ich mal auf die
seite die kräutergärtner nicht
ich werde nämlich zuerst die sahne steif
schlagen das mache ich einfach in einem
hohen gefäß meinen ofen habe ich jetzt
übrigens schon mal vorgeheizt 175 grad
ober und unterhitze und hat jetzt die
sahne steif schlagen
es mache ich es einfach mit dem
handrührgerät weil ich für dieses kleine
rezept jetzt nicht die große
küchenmaschine benutzen will
dann nehme ich mir einfach eine ganz
normale und geht da den frischkäse ein
tipp vorweg gesagt es ist schon spät
dann kommt dann sogar mit rein zweier
und ihr wisst ich machte mir ganz gern
dass ich die eier zu essen und extra
gefäß aufschlag weiß nie ob nicht mal
ein schlechtes dabei ist ich hole meine
frisch
einfach vergessen wurde oder schlechte
reinfeldt und da wird das ganze einmal
verrührt dieser krebs nehme ich jetzt
einfach ein drittel raus dann nämlich
einfach die schlüssel in der ich wohne
die größe zerkrümelt habe ungefähr
hinkommen da gebe ich jetzt dass kaka
obwohl von mit rein
ich versuche es noch mal ganz schnell
und dann gebe ich etwa ein drittel der
saane hier betreiben und die restlichen
zwei drittel zu dieser hellen creme wird
es mit dem zweiten drittel das macht ja
einfach nur augenmaß und damit dieser
wieder einmal unter gehoben das macht
die creme ein freches leichter ich mache
ja das rezept hier zum ersten mal und
habt es einfach mal umgerechnet das
rezept war ausgelegt von 20 zentimeter
springform und weichteile 220 er habe
habe ich es runtergerechnet 18
und ich werde statt normale tabelle auf
meinem blog veröffentlichen
ich finde es ja immer so witzig wenn ihr
nach diesen um rechnungs formeln und so
weiter fragt weil die liebe zu schauen
in köln stellen da immer so eine richtig
coole rechnung einstellen weil immerhin
schreibt jahres geht das einfach mal
keine ahnung und stellte einfach so eine
hochkomplexe sich nicht kompliziert aber
sie kompliziert auf und ich stelle euch
da sein
eine tabelle rein da gibt's dann nämlich
um rechnungen zu zahlen
und wenn ihr zb von am 22 zentimeter auf
1 810 errechnet dann müsst ihr einfach
zum beispiel 200 gramm zucker 130 gramm
zu übernehmen also die umrechnung zahl
ist 067 zu häufig sitzt gemacht und habe
eben statt 230 genommen statt 3 1 oder 2
und so weiter und so könnt ihr rezept
aber hoch ich dann also wenn ihr dieses
rezept größer machen wollt benutzt ihr
eben die andere zahl die über ein
und da das vereinfachte steinway so ein
bisschen aber ich sage trocknende hält
kühl stellen dafür dass sie das immer so
mit viel geduld den anderen zuschauern
erklärt ich 1510 und dieses rezept
veröffentliche ich euch natürlich auf
meinem blog
und ich möchte auch gleich nochmals zur
nutzerfreundlichkeit von manchen
rezepten schlagen und zwar nicht nur
bezogen auf dieses heft ich finde es
sehr viele stärken mut und auch rezepte
immer gut aber die rezept beschreibungen
finde ich nicht immer für gut weil ich
glaube dass viele rezepte einfach auch
aus dem englischen übersetzt leiten ins
deutsche und dann achte mal gar nicht
mehr darauf oft auch der rezept fluss
eben stimmt dann steht die ganze zeit
zum beispiel die springform die
springform die springform und dann steht
plötzlich eine springform heißt für mich
es kommt eine neue dazu aber eigentlich
sprechen sie immer noch von der gleichen
also dass ein bisschen verwirrend
einfach auch für menschen die vielleicht
nicht so viel backen oder sich nicht
vorstellen können wie das rezept
funktioniert und deswegen finde ich will
jetzt meinen tortenboden raum bzw
und ich weiß nicht ob ich dieses jahr
noch schafe aber das wäre mein
zukunftsgedanken und ich hoffe dass ich
sie es ja auch hinbekommen
ich werde mich ganz gern einen kochbuch
und auch ein backbuch veröffentlicht
und ja da lasst euch einfach überraschen
jetzt gebe ich zuerst diese dunkle masse
auf den teig richtig lecker schokolade
und verteilen ist einfach schön
verstreichen ohne richtig schöne feste
creme kommt eben durch diese frischkäse
gräben und schmeckt richtig schön
schokoladen finger weg da kommt immer
der kleine finger große hier das gebe
ich dir zum abschlecken nehme ich
nämlich den kleinen kommt da die heli
creme obendrauf
ganz vorsichtig und die versuchen war
richtig schön glatt zu streichen nehmen
hier diese show und ich kann mir auch
ganz gut vorstellen dass man ihnen diese
helle creme noch ein aroma gibt zum
beispiel vanilla zitrone will ich es
nicht machen wegen den erdnüssen und
auch wegen dem parallel der später nach
oben drauf kommt aber man könnte die
berichtigungen schnell in form von
vanille zucker
die presept steht jetzt dass der kuchen
eben gebacken wird
aber er wird mich einfach so genommen
und im backofen gebacken sondern in eine
große reform gestimmt und die größere
form kommt etwas wasser und dann wieder
so gebackenen praktisch wie so eine art
soufflé macht mir auch und damit die
springform eben kein wasser rein trinkt
wird das ganze mit alu folie versehen
das macht ihr so das sind die abenteuer
einer auszeit in zwei bahnen die sich
kreuzen
von außen verschieden uns dann kommt
nämlich keine
und jetzt kommt das so viel wasser haben
dass etwa die hälfte der frauen perfekt
ist
dass marica zur stelle und ich denke es
liegt einfach daran dass man möchte dass
dieser kuchen eben gleichmäßig auf geht
auch auf jeden fall gleichmäßig back to
nicht einreißt und auf tonga schön
saftig bleibt jetzt fehlt noch ein
bisschen wasser und so wie er jetzt bei
175 grad ober und unterhitze für etwa 50
minuten gebacken bei einer größeren form
bei der 22er springform wir eine stunde
gebacken und ich werde dann testen oder
durch ist ich rücke dann einfach ein
bisschen dran und dann darf eben nicht
mehr erwarten das heißt die eimasse wird
er geschockt sein und da muss der kuchen
auf jeden fall bei geöffneter tür bei
ausgeschaltetem rufen noch etwa eine
halbe stunde der auskühlen und dann
herausgenommen werden jetzt meinen
kuchen im ofen und ich möchte jetzt noch
eine zuschauerfrage beantworten die ich
immer wieder gestellt bekommen und zwar
weil ich oft gefragt wie ich das immer
schaffe dass die küche dann während dem
backen wie das sauber aussieht und zwar
ist vom grundprinzip von mir ich
organisiert ist ganz gern also wie ich
backe und max ich backe und möchte dann
während der bakken schon dass alles
wieder schön sauber aufgeräumt wird weil
mir das einfach nach dem backen die zeit
und erspart also auch beim kochen ist
genau so strukturiert über meinen
arbeitsplatz so bringt es auf den
schüler in der schule bei und möchte
nach jedem arbeitsschritt auch dass die
küche wieder sauber ist weil ich einfach
im endeffekt arbeitszeit sparen will und
eben meine bezahlt und arbeitszeit
effektiv mütze und das solltet ihr auch
machen weil ich das wirklich zum schluss
viel arbeit erspart weil ich glaube ich
gibt nix frustrierend da es also wenn
man in kuchen gebacken hat und dann noch
so ein riesenkampf schlachtfeld hat und
das aufräumen muss jemanden sehen wir
hier das bei der
gemacht und dann kochen ist genau das
gleiche
ich möchte dann einfach nach dem essen
wenn ich satt bin und vollwertig sonst
so etwas müde
und da möchte ich nicht noch mal die
küche und sanieren grund aufräumen
müssen sondern dann einfach geschehen
schön in die spülmaschine ein und kann
dann entweder vom spaziergang machen
oder mich einfach die couch legen oder
irgendwas anderes machen und habe
einfach die sorge weg und bin nach
richtig schön entspannt so sieht der
kuchen jetzt nach den fakten aus und ich
habe jetzt seit einer stunde da drin
also länger als 50 minuten und ich war
immer ganz kurz also ihr seht da ist
noch etwas weich aber ich denke da ist
so richtig gut und ich werde den ofen
ausschalten und den kuchen jetzt einfach
so bei leicht geöffneter tür etwa 30
minuten abkühlen lassen und ihnen dann
daraus nehmen und erst mal komplett
abkühlen lassen und dann in den
kühlschrank stellen
bis zum nächsten morgen ich hatte jetzt
meinen kuchen schön kalt stehen
ich habe ihn bei den temperaturen auf
den balkon gestellt natürlich könnt ihr
ihn auch nach dem erkalten aus dem open
in den kühlschrank stellen
aber wenn wir schon die temperaturen
haben bietet sich das natürlich an
ich hatte ihn über nacht draußen stehen
aber es reichen auch ein paar stunden
einfach so dass er richtig schön kalt
ist und so sieht der kuchen jetzt aus
und den wenn ich jetzt einmal aus der
form lösen
dann habe ich den einmal hier hohe und
ich habe hier noch das backpapier
drunter und vater jetzt erstmal mit
seinem topmodell terrain
erst richtig schön kalt von daher
passierte auch nicht so schnell was
wie habt ihr jetzt ein käsekuchen schon
fertig und könnt ihr jetzt auch so
servieren
aber ich möchte den natürlich sowie im
rezept auch mit einer karamell schicht
um schicht zu bereiten und dafür zeige
ich euch die zutaten für die karre
menschlich für die karamell schicht
braucht ihr 80,5 zehn gramm butter und
50 gramm sahne und die karamell schlicht
weil es jetzt hier auf dem herd
zubereitet und zwar gebt ihr den zucker
in einem kleinen topf oder eine pfanne
und lass dir schön karamellisieren
dann bist du dann auch richtig aufpassen
das geht richtig schnell und dann gebt
ihr das schnell die zuschauer mit ein
da müsste ich vorsichtig sein karamell
ist richtig richtig heiß da könnt euch
richtig die finger verbrennen und das
biest ihr jetzt einfach über euren
kuchen und zwar die sich das jetzt hier
schnell drauf und da müsste jetzt auch
schnell arbeiten weil er der kuchen
richtig kalt ist und das karamell schön
fest wird gleich mit so einer winkel und
es darf ruhig am rand etwas runter
laufen
habe ich ein bisschen zu langsam
gearbeitet ich jetzt schneller schicken
müssen
aber das macht jetzt nichts weiter jetzt
auch gleich eine schoko creme drauf
kommt aber er hätte das ruhig richtig
ganz schnell darauf geben können so dass
es richtig schön am rand unterläuft dann
entstehen wir auch ganz schöne tröpfchen
unter leitung von anfragen
macht aber nichts denn kuchen stellt
jetzt ernst kurz in den kühlschrank oder
wieder auf die terrasse und wälzt
solange die show vorzubereiten
für den schocker guss habe ich hier 70
gramm sahne und 70 gramm schokolade
ich habe jetzt hier eine extra zahlt
bitterschokolade genommen mit 72 prozent
kakaoanteil
ihr könnt natürlich aber auch eine ganz
normale zartbitterschokolade nehmen oder
auch vollmilch weil es jetzt nicht so
schokolade schmeckt aber wir essen ganz
gerne die mit fiel kaká und deswegen
nehme ich jetzt die ohne stand kommt die
sahne hier in einen kleinen topf im
prinzip wird sowas wie einer garage
hergestellt die in einen des schokokuss
ist auch okay und jetzt werde ich die
sahne einmal kurz aufkochen lassen
im rezept steht man sondern auch noch
ein kleines stückchen palmen mit dazu
geben das mache ich jetzt auch noch das
sind so etwa fünf bis sechs gramm und
sobald die sahne koch schaltete den herd
aus
die sahne runter und gibt da jetzt die
kleinen gemachte schokolade mit rein
dass das jetzt einfach ganz kurz zu
stehen
nach etwa zwei drei minuten wird das
ganze schön verrührt und so sollte es
dann zum schluss aussehen und ist
irritiert aus der karamell richtig schön
fest geworden ist wo ich wenn mir
natürlich an die frage gestellt wie kann
man den kuchen anschneiden aber es war
später sehen und jetzt ihr diese
schokolade diesen schokoladenguss und
gießt ihn hier einmal drüber und das
nochmals diesmal ganz schnell
ich glaube ich mach das jetzt einfach so
ich brauche dazu gar keine palette
einen kick geben bis die schokolade fest
geworden ist und sobald sie fest ist
wenn wir ihn zusammen anschauen und
ausprobieren sowie der falte gekommen
jetzt aus und ich werde jetzt einmal
schneiden und euch auch zeigen
ich nehme das schon richtig scharfes
messer ich hab da so ein messer und
tollen heber in einem und wetter auch
heißes wasser dafür benutzen um eben
zwischendurch immer wieder besser sauber
zu machen
mit der karamell karamell ich ein
bisschen zu fest
das mag ich an so rezepten natürlich was
nach machen dann geht's einfach hat man
es hat mir schon gesehen dass es
karamell festes schneiden lassen wird
finde ich echt bisschen wird ich denke
ich wird da viel mehr sahne dazugeben
und doch unmöglich jedem ein ganzer
käsekuchen
es war also so sieht es jetzt im innern
aus eine kleine katastrophe
ich werde etwas enttäuscht über den
kuchen und ich glaube dass ich mein
erstes rezept video welches ich euch
nicht empfehlen kann
und ich bin echt ziemlich frustrierend
wenn ich ein heft kaufen und dann
richtig lecker das titelbild see und am
einige fehler meister mal wieder von
fotografen mit dabei die haben da
irgendwelche künstlichen sachen gemacht
was hier auch so sehr stark einkommen
kein echter kann er gar nicht nach dem
rezept gebacken sein
die cara menschlich die ich so fest also
das ist gar keine karamellsoße sondern
richtig karamell am tag da würde ich
empfehle besser anzunehmen wenn ich es
überhaupt machen weil ich will die
kammer mensch ich kann auch rechnen
ich probiere mal ihren den käsekuchen
also der käsekuchen richtig lecker
geschmeckt
das einzige was mich wirklich tierisch
aufgeregt ich diese karamell schicht ich
meine ich finde auch einen bug anfänger
oder kochen empfänger und ich habe auch
selbst schon auf karamellsoße gemacht
und dachte ich hab mich jetzt mal
wirklich 100% anderes objekt und dann
finde ich das wirklich sehr ärgerlich
und windkraft enttäuscht darüber dass es
so einfach nicht klappt meine empfehlung
für euch ich diesen leckeren käse und
entwickelt rec nach machen wollt dann
lasst die cara menschliche entweder weg
oder nehmt ein etwas mehr sein und ihr
müsst ihr auch die cara menschen nicht
komplett überlaufen lassen so dass so
eine richtig fette knusprige decke
drüber ist sondern das einfach so ein
bisschen karamell drüber läuft der
käsekuchen ich wirklich lecker auch mit
dem größten boden und mit dem schoko
teig in uns drin aber ich finde das echt
einfach nicht ich hab mir gestern abend
und heute morgen mühe gegeben und habt
ihr leid und ein kleines chaos
ich werde euch dann auf jeden fall
dieses veränderte rezept auf meinem blog
bei www.stargebot.de hochladen und falls
der eine oder andere sich doch noch
trocknen kuchen nacht machen was ich
wirklich zu empfehlen kann weil es ihr
wirklich lecker ist dann kostet mir
gerne eure fotos auf facebook und wir
sehen uns dann beim nächsten mal wieder
lasst mir gerne einen kommentare
vielleicht ich euch auch schon so oft
passiert mit so hetzen oder räuchern das
ja was ausprobiert habt und es klappt
einfach nicht da habe ich auch mal gerne
eure erfahrungen hören und freue mich
schon aufs nächste mal probiert und dann
kommt wieder ein eigenes netz
informieren
trotzdem schmecken tut gut verändert